you know we were 20 when the internet
was even starting to start to start
and and it was definitely not like
the same as like it is today and now
it's completely flipped upside down so
john 15 year old john right now only
dreams of going viral or winning on the
internet
and 48 year old john still
subconsciously because of the way he
grew up
thinks of it as a step down i understand
both
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
well this is exciting for me those are
remade migos those aren't original
miko's that's what i love that's all of
yes they are they're called
figures from figures toy store uh
figures toy company
i looked for my old me you're the
perfect person for this by the way we
started the podcast um
i love it uh because everything
everything that i've been learning about
you uh with going to like garage sales i
guess
and uh and ebay and all that kind of
stuff so here's
here's what i was looking for a podcast
set and i was trying to think what is
me what what what what talks about me
what tells about into my childhood
which is where i wish i still was so i
went looking
like i went looking for my migo toys oh
i must have sold them at a garage sale
to some guy who became famous on the
internet
uh and uh but i couldn't find them and
you know there were some on ebay and
stuff like that i did get some
but there were figures toys and i just
looked it up and they're remakes of the
migos the
i think they're five and a half inch
also had the little ones too the migo
minis or whatever they're called but
they were you know they were those dogs
they were really dolls they weren't
action figures correct uh and they were
awesome
as a kid growing up and uh everything's
changed so much i had todd mcfarland on
and you talk about going the exact
opposite way
the detail in those was incredible these
are like they take the same head and
just paint it differently
100 yeah they were barbies
and let's call them what they want yes
and it's and and then
and when i was growing up my dad would
have been mad at that and nowadays it
would be
it would be perfect it would be 100 way
to go
so uh you are the guest today gary vee
um
which and i didn't know much about you
i'm honest on this podcast
a lot of times i used to try i used to
try and be
uh something i wasn't i used to try and
be a really good host
you're one of the people actually i've
heard talk about this
uh you know talk about being yourself
and that comes through um and i get lost
you know i'm all over the place that's
why i do the impressions i bet
really oh yeah i'm i'm very i can be
focused when i'm
like building a business but like i'm
the worst
i also on my podcast i'm terrible i cut
off the person 747
my fans like want to punch me in the
face when i'm like doing
i i yeah i'm just i'm quite creative
in in a lot of ways that i didn't
realize as a kid because i i
all the creative energy went into
business and that didn't seem creative
back then
back to your earlier point of your dad
and adult like that like
creativity and not like the word
entrepreneur didn't even exist i was
going to be a businessman
and that that seemed like money and
money didn't seem like creative or art
or things that nature
but like yeah i mean i i have like six
thoughts right now i'm like thinking
about your ghostbuster figures
i was pumped to see plastic man in the
background like i'm like thinking about
the hogan figure
i'm thinking about some of your
impressions that i've loved like like
was i mad because i saw that in
before jets game that was bad like it's
amazing how many places in 13 seconds
your brain can actually go
yeah and that see well i would not have
thought that at all see i would have
thought you were extremely focused you
know i i did uh what got me in i call it
i call it controlled chaos i'm focused
when when i'm on a i can be micro
focused
but i'm i'm macro most happy
in chaos could you stop interrupting me
so
yes uh no that i uh
i wouldn't have thought that because i
so i go back to when i started i got off
the internet so my story is this
i uh when i was starting to
make a little bit of a name for myself
uh back in fox nfl sunday
and uh doing stuff on on tbs and even a
little bit mad tv the internet was just
starting to
to blow up a little bit when i first got
to hollywood people didn't even really
have email their
email was just starting and people like
i had a manager's like you're not going
to believe this you can type a message
to somebody on the keyboard
and you send it across the country and
they get it in seconds
so that world i was at one point
the number one thing on youtube before
there were any subscribers or anything
like that just
youtube uh people there was even a thing
where people like uh
the frank caliendo factor of youtube
where people you know small blogs would
talk about that type of thing
but i got lost in it i i didn't i didn't
see it like when
when microsoft didn't see what apple saw
i didn't see the future of that which is
very common frank i actually i remember
you on youtube i was there very early
with wine library tv in february 2006
um when it was like rocket boom and zay
frank and all this stuff
i i know because hollywood or if
you thought of yourself that way these
things were a
micro little stepping stone to the big
game youtube was like a small
club you would play on your way like
every but i remember it vividly
that the that two thousand two three
four five six
seven era really then started to change
but like 01 to 06
to your point it was like a place you
were
using to get somewhere and what i
definitely understood back then was like
no no this is going to be this somewhere
yeah because i was i was actually
getting mad about it i was
more i had more people recognizing me
from
youtube at the time than i did when
after doing letterman
and that annoyed me that and that's the
wrong way to look at it that's what i've
learned
is you know perspective is everything
that's something you talk about ed
milette was another guy who's
gotten me into i saw some of your i saw
all of your interview with ed
um but ed was one i was starting to get
back into the internet i got away from
it
uh just because i was on twitter and i
was building an audience on twitter
and it was so angry i described it as
like new york city being in manhattan
and when you're walking in times square
and everybody's bumping into each other
and nobody cares and they just start
swearing at each other and they don't
care
uh i just i just couldn't hack it i mean
it was one of those things i was sitting
there so i just got away
but i i met ed and started getting into
it i learned about you
um and some of the other influencers i
don't know if you even like that term
um i'll tell you know at this point you
get so you know
to your point it's funny like
when you put yourself out there and i'm
sure you this happens for you and really
at this point because everybody puts
themselves out there
everybody's getting labeled as something
like you
you i'm just grateful that i have the
chance to be labeled
you know whatever that label is i'll
just you know so
keep going well i did listen
what i was thinking about is does well i
want to go with your labeling thing does
that
does it uh it doesn't annoy you at all i
mean
i recognize it's kind of like your gift
is your curse
i you know have built businesses my
whole life
and built a huge business for my dad in
the wine and liquor business
you know in the last 24 months had
a restaurant app called resi that i
started co-founded with ben leventhal
um sell for hefty nine figures to amex i
sold my direct to consumer wine brand
empathy wines
for almost 100 million dollars
vaynermedia
is a 200 million a year almost 200
million year revenue based
business that i've started from scratch
yet
when i get when i get mentioned on the
internet and you read the comments
everyone's like
well he's just a [ __ ] motivational
speaker and so
you know as any human when you work your
face off and you accomplish
you know it's funny to answer you
because even as i'm saying it
ultimately i don't
mind because i understand how human
beings are wired thus
is why i've done well but yeah i mean
you know i think we all get miffed
you know i don't want to be you know i
love perspective and mindset because i
think it's foundational
to helping people go do things but i
think there's a lot of
i think there's a lot of characters that
you know just speak for the sake of
speaking
and don't have the resume or the
execution underneath them and
of course there's times that i wish that
was recognized more but
you know i also know that when you have
drillions of videos
of you speaking on stage being consumed
that's the only context and so i have to
be empathetic because i'm the one
creating those videos and distributing
them
well you know i can relate to that a lot
because when i used to get mad at people
seeing me as just the impressionist guy
but then i realized that's all i'm
putting out there
i'm putting that out there constantly
not only putting it out there the
platform you had i mean that's
definitely the first time i became aware
of it like
when so many of the percentage of people
see that because the platform
was so big that you were being consumed
on
to your point this is about empathy to
the end user of understanding well
that's what they see
so do you think as i knew uh
i know a little bit about your story
that you built your
your parents wine business was worth
like
three million dollars it was it was
doing three million dollars a year
and i grew it to a business that was
doing 65 million dollars a year in an
eight year period
and that's by bringing it to the
internet and realizing you didn't need
to
email 8 000 stores your story about
youtube hollywood was my story about
email versus catalogs
i understood in 1997 that the biggest
stores in the country
sam's in chicago sherry lehmann's and
zaki's in new york
wine club and wine exchange and k l
wines these stores that i looked up to
because i've been in the business since
i was 14
and the wednesday new york times dining
edition would have all the national
ads and i was like one day i'm going to
help my dad and i'm going to take us to
the national level
like these stores and those stores that
i just rattled off or those stores
i realized in 1997 that i could email
out opus one or don perrion or silver
oak or kamis or these great wines on
email for free back to the agent joke
you made earlier
while my competitors these iconic stores
were taking three months producing a
catalog that cost them a crapload of
money
and cost a lot of money to deliver and
would be two months
two weeks six weeks six days later that
i could email it
and and i really really took advantage
of that
and i understood that this was crazy
this is what people thought in 1996.
i understood that rich people that
bought expensive wine
would use email and reply and say they
want six bottles
and literally like this crazy for every
listener people debated me saying that
the affluent
individuals wouldn't like that
experience i would rather order it from
a catalog people always do that they do
it now
instagram influencers didn't go on
tick-tock
because they were insecure and didn't
want to start all over so they would
make up excuses that tick tock was
only for girls dancing when it was
obvious what was happening there
people don't like change and i love
change and that has been a huge
foundation in my career
yeah that you're you're kind of
describing me with even tick tock there
i didn't want to get on it at the
beginning tick tock
was recruiting me to to get on there now
this is when it had just switched over
from musically
and i looked at it and i would open it
up
and i felt like i was going to go to
jail every time
something played i get that and it's
changed it's changed and i think
especially i guess the vine people found
it
people like you found it but what
happened was that it evolved
and even now when i tell people about
tick tock i'm like it's not the same
it's not just uh sounds and stuff like
that and
um uh you know uh
lip syncing it's it's a lot of
content frank that's the thing that i'm
good
at as well and i think other people that
have the investing or business career
that i have
are also good at they're able to look at
mtv in 1984
and say okay this is not free music i
don't know if you know this story
most of the big bands in the early late
70s early 80s refused to make music
videos because they thought it was
giving away free music
and sticks for example because i
remember speaking to the stick's manager
literally decided not to make videos
because
that was giving away music for free [ __ ]
you meanwhile duran duran and van halen
and and you know and twisted sister were
thrilled to do it and be then became
the biggest bands in the world in that
era
i've always valued the attention
of society over the short term economics
of the transaction
of a sale so i would rather
go to the new place work hard figure out
how to bring value through my content
there and be there when it became the
thing
versus somebody i like how you just
reacted where do you mind just go
i'm laughing because you're exactly the
opposite of
everything i've ever thought that i've
realized i was wrong about
recently everything that i i've always
put a value when people would ask me
hey are you gonna you're gonna go up to
the comedy store you're gonna go up to
the laugh factory
and do a set when i lived in la i live
in arizona now
i just thought it'd be a better place to
to raise a family and stuff outside of
hollywood
so uh which is part of my issue i made a
choice
i've heard you talk about you know time
management and stuff with that family
versus i made a conscious choice
my guilt with family and stuff which i
i'm
i should guilt seems like a negative
connotation but it's
that's what it was but it's it's what i
cared about i'm glad that i'm here for
my kids
even dancing because it's it's a it's a
mix of gratitude and guilt
yeah and it's trying to find that
balance i it is i i
i went way over to the family side
because i just knew
that was me i just i just anyways no no
let's stay here
because i think it's going to help a lot
of people because i love you know we're
getting to know each other i love you
for that
because you clearly it's funny you talk
professionally about the chess moves but
i actually think in your real life
clearly what you care about the most you
actually saw foresaw the game which is
one day my kids are gonna be 20 i'm
never going to get this back
that's exactly what it was i can feel it
i literally have goosebumps i don't know
if you can see him through the screen
i was like this guy's interesting he
realized it in the real life
but professionally because it was so
pushed on him
that make people pay for your your value
did it like people it in hollywood and
in wall street and in madison avenue
they over value like restriction
and they undervalue awareness
yeah i mean i've always been super aware
of everything like comedy clubs i bet
awareness from like
every rep matters because if one more
person knows who you are that's going to
matter long term and a lot of the
monetization and restrictions
my favorite one hollywood's obsessed
with overexposure there's no
overexposure
not anything well there used to be but
there you go you said there's a new
perspective on stuff there isn't there
used to be
ish what happened was music was hard
and like playing the fawns was hard like
overexposure was very unique
it was people would get caught with such
an iconic role that we couldn't stop
seeing them in that role from an acting
standpoint the fonz
you know um whoever we can do a million
of these you know
urkel like you know tony soprano
um but and then artists would get a lot
of plays
and it was to your point there was only
mtv i mean you if you're madonna and you
were promoting a
a new album you could actually get all
of america to know it was out
if you did 13 things that world doesn't
exist anymore
right well and i think people have been
desensitized
if you're look if you're if you open up
tick-tock you might see the guy playing
the straw hammer whatever that is
five times in the next 10 minutes that
person
seems overexposed i guess not even
overexposed that person seems like you
see them just as much as you see
let's say michael strahan who's doing
six jobs on television
so we don't even see it anymore we don't
understand it because it's
changed so much in front of us what
you're actually describing is a
different point in my opinion which is
the attention of
the world is in a different place and so
if you're in the business world
of entertainment you know that michael
strahan does six shows
and he's unbelievably successful in
classic hollywood and entertainment
terms but if you're living in the
practical world
you're realizing that attention is
staggeringly
quickly shifting to 15 platforms on the
internet and whoever
is winning there is winning yeah i i
mean i didn't even think i
see i i still lump it all together i
still have
what you are able to do is
compartmentalize and see these different
pieces of media and that's what that's
just me trying to go from old school
to this new school way of thinking i
mean uh
pat mcafee do you know pat mcafee huge
podcast
um he's he's the guy who actually got me
back
into the internet he started he started
me going he's like you should
you should be killing on there doing
voiceovers doing this doing that i was
like ah
and i i didn't want to because i thought
keep going
well i just i'll tell you this keep
going you're good at that
uh i just didn't want to because i saw
myself and my podcast partner who's not
here right now
this is the way he still thinks and we
fight about this all the time
fight in terms of he's the number he's
the number one radio guy in phoenix
he's he's a he's a he's a seven figure
guy he's set
and he's really happy which is perfect
and i've heard you talk about that too
when you're happy with where you're at
that's great five figures
six figures seven figures when you're
happy game over
and probably the most talented guy i've
ever met with
impressions the ability he's kind of
like a combination of
you know the shock jock dj who can also
do the sidekick stuff
in terms of impressions characters he's
got it all i mean
he and i go back and forth we work on
impressions together it's
it's it's a great teamwork and dichotomy
so we we get along really well because
we think he's like a
slightly more evil version of me uh
which is in this world good and bad but
he's edgier
and he takes a lot more risks i find
myself working in corporate america a
lot
so i don't take as many chances i back
off quite a bit
but he doesn't he doesn't like the
internet at all and i get i got back on
the internet and started getting on
there
and i said i have to find this new
audience what does he not like about it
frank i apologize i'm just curious uh
you know it just feels like a step down
to him although
he did he grow up wanting to be an
entertainer
i i think he grew up wanting to do radio
i think that's he wanted to be a
writer too yeah i mean that's listen
it's the e it's this
it's the song is all this time like
every 15 year old
in america right now 13 year old wants
to be an influencer when they grow up
that was no i you know what i'd say that
except for my kid
fair enough but you know of course you
know i'm just no i i know i know i just
my son's gonna listen to this uh i'm a
year younger than or
older than you so born in 74 how old are
you i'm i turned 45
uh in a couple weeks here so i'm 46 i'll
be 47 in january
so couple things when you and i were
growing up you know
be you know being an actor or
or you know on tv was
you know and i didn't want to be because
i wanted to be a businessman but
like half the class did or or or in a
different way
almost all of us would have taken it do
you know what i mean i think some people
were you know and i think
to your point i mean the ideology of
your partner
was in that era so to also
how is he in our age group in the
general range yeah he's two years older
than me i think
perfect so he's like joe right so john
like
you know we were 20 when the internet
was even
starting to start to start and and
it was definitely not like the same as
like it is today and now it's completely
flipped upside down so john
15 year old john right now only dreams
of going viral or winning on the
internet
and 48 year old john still
subconsciously because of the way he
grew up
thinks of it as a step down i understand
both i mean i felt i
i felt like that a lot until i realized
hey i got to get in front of a lot of
different people
i my i i struggle with this too because
this is another thing i've heard you
talk about i feel like i'm in a therapy
session with you it's good
um uh but it's
i it's been a learning experience and
it's been a difficult
step for me to to put some stuff out
it's hard on tic toc these kids don't
know me at all it's funny because i'll
get people
these kids will tell me things like oh
that impression sucks i'm like well it
built this
70 000 gallon pool it's
good enough by the way by the way frank
i'll be honest with you play with me
here a little bit this could be
interesting
i think that should be something you try
i think the best thought about it i
forgot about it but let me tell you
something this is
very very big this is a this is the
whole this is the punch line of this
podcast
and we're going to help three people who
are listening right now i can feel it in
my soul
the biggest difference between what made
you great and you became you
and this exact second is that i
thought about it is the vulnerability
you know you you grew up in a world i
get it i'm going to cry you're going to
make me cry you're going to be gary
because it's great you see frankie see
with you i'm excited about this because
because the i thought about it
once by the way kevin james let's talk
about kevin james kevin james's team
calls me
a year ago whatever 15 months ago we get
on the call
we have this i'm on i remember i'm in
california on the highway in between
meetings just on a call
and we had this like really interesting
i just had like a 30 minute like jam
session with them
because you know kevin's a jets fan you
know we'd interacted a little bit
and there was just something i don't
remember what but something landed
in the same way that i'm trying to land
with you don't think about it
and it just and all of us i just
remember the whole team the writing team
and him on there
and it clicked and so much good has
happened
on tick tock and other things for him
since
and i genuinely believe the same thing
would happen for you which is
in a world where you perfected [ __ ]
before you showed the world
what what's so fun about this is you get
to perfect it
with them not without them and and when
i tell you
that if you started a whole shtick
of you razzing the kids razzing you like
in the meta of it
that would [ __ ] crush well this is
going to become a tick tock itself with
you saying that that'll justify the
reason for me doing it
that's what i that's what i needed was
listen i i thought about that i thought
about taking the replies the you know
the uh reply videos the comments the
negative comments
i'd even i even mapped one out in my
head here are the following impressions
people say
on tick tock that's that i do that they
say suck
a that you should 100 do that b when you
make a video
saying hey ricky pants 67
and and you then show him saying this
sucks
be like you think that sucks what about
you know like wherever you go with it
whatever the transition is but see okay
so you're jumping into a world of
okay see i love the idea of
hey i'll show you but at the same time
you've got to be very careful yeah i
love you already i like to struggle with
i don't want to put but you know where
i'm going i know because then i look
like the big bad
wolf
no no you play with it for fun like
like you'll appreciate this and i can
i'm getting a sense of you
you know what you know what has
absolutely worked for me and others
intent right people like gary v
like you know and that would be the tone
of it as well right the tone the way you
play where you invite the kid to swim
like there's a million places you can do
it
you see where i'm going i invite the kid
to swim during combat
i got these other four kids they're
coughing it'll be fun
okay here's my iron man jackass but
it it really is intense i remember when
i first started putting out content 2009
and i didn't know this and this goes
into your world a little bit i didn't
realize
how much richard pryor and i listened to
so much richard pryor and eddie murphy
and chris rock as a kid
like when i drove it was sports radio or
tape of stand-up and
and so i'm 34 years old when i give my
first
keynote speech about business and when i
tell you i had no [ __ ] idea what was
gonna happen when i went on stage i had
no idea i just
went on there and what happened was
when the lights went on for some reason
i decided
that i was going to communicate as if i
was doing a set
in a very improv and it was really funny
to me
that that happened and i think what
uh so i was cursing like crazy and
i was getting so much pushback it was
you know 12 years ago it was a different
time
with and and i remember people
begging me to change my style caa who
did my speaking
because i hit very quickly and became
hot and ca was doing my speaking at the
time
and they begged me big shout out to
peter jacobs
they begged me to stop cursing they were
like
you know you will make so much it's back
to your point earlier about corporate
america and the way you think about what
you're going to do and not do
and before you go on already i know
peter jacobs that's the high end keep
going
yeah so exactly so though i i
just couldn't do it i just needed to do
me and was willing to deal with the
ramifications and then the world
came to me and the reason it happened
was i had a
tent i it's how i actually spoke it's
how i naturally felt
and i had good intent i wasn't trying to
hurt people i was trying to use it to
get them to hear it and i think if you
come out with intent
of not being a big shot but just having
fun with the community and enjoying
yourself
i think i mean it makes sense it makes
sense because you can do that in a
jovial way
correct that's what i'm trying to do
with the podcast that's what i'm trying
to do with everything
listen i'm trying to get people to
understand who i am and where because
i'm i'm much more sarcastic in real life
i'm
i'm goofy and stuff like that but people
see me as the
walks the line maybe goes even halfway
to the line but on the podcast they go
all the way line sometimes go over the
line it's me i
you know we say things behind the scenes
well you don't you talk exactly
i maybe i shouldn't say i don't know you
that well but you go out there and what
you're showing is you you're bearing
your soul
when you go out there and that's what i
that's what listen these impressions
that i do
it's a mask for me to hide right it's a
way for me i'm a kid who grew up
watching all these tv
shows of all the stuff you saw behind me
i was by myself
playing with my legos my parents like
you ever gonna come out of your room no
i have my friends they're the super
friends they're
meanwhale in frank's room he's putting
together a lego set
you know that's that's who i was and
hiding is what i've always been and this
this internet stuff when i go out there
and look
uh you know you see people the best
people
are the people who put it all out there
and you see the emotion i learned this i
didn't i didn't apologize real quick the
ones that have the sustained
sustained success are the ones because
there's a lot of people
to your point who are absolutely putting
up facades without acknowledging it
the beauty of impressions is i know
let me rephrase i don't think most
people enjoy psychology enough
to know that that's what you were doing
but i do whereas a lot of people are
saying they're being authentic it's why
you know but then but then not and
they're the ones that can't have
sustained
success to your point the sustained
success
you know fun it is to not have to think
frank i never have to think
everything i talk i talk i like there's
no like oh
like when i go to the restaurant like oh
i better be like when you could just be
yourself 24
7. i'd love to get there man it's that's
an amazing
i'm getting better at it but dennis
miller started screaming at me on a
podcast he's like frankie just me
you jochie what are you doing he's just
screaming at me to just be myself and i
it's people don't understand i've built
these walls around me this was a thing i
noticed i learned on tick tock
um i did i you know i do the impressions
i haven't even gotten to the part of
really showing the me
stuff and even on tick-tock and what i
do
differently there and the reason i keep
referencing tick-tock i find it the
fastest place to grow
growing like crazy and you're being more
creative
yes there's a there's a level of
creativity but what
and what gets me to do it the motivation
is the ability to grow quickly i mean
it's
it's uh you know what i love you for
that
sentence like that's a big deal to
acknowledge that because i'll be honest
with you
i love that as an entree but
you have to basically spend all your
time
getting out of that mindset because it's
similar to being in the room
with the legos the judgment of others
and calibrating it is everything yeah
the reason real celebrities hate social
media is they don't want the insecurity
of low numbers
and tick tocks work right absolutely all
the time
you see something going down and i have
a group of friends we go
we are getting you know people will just
text me all the time
what is the algorithm doing like i i
don't know i just i've started to just
give up on that and throw i would hide
i used to hide the low number ones and
then i looked around at some of the
i i realized a lot of people are doing
that a lot of people are
deleting hiding screw it
whatever nobody gives a [ __ ] at the end
yeah
in the end nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah i
i mean i don't know i don't know i just
it for me it's hard to because they're
it's trying to go from an old mindset of
what we used to look at here's my thing
my biggest thing is you have so much
creative talent
i'm devastated that you overthinking
something
may stop you from making your signature
piece of work
well that's where i'm getting to this
point that's where i'm getting to a
point is
i'm getting to a point where i've said
i'm just going to start throwing a lot
more stuff out there i've heard you
talking about i've heard them by the way
it's not spray and pray and throw
against the wall and see what sucks
these are actual thoughts in your mind
and you're going to put them out
that's a big difference a lot of people
like oh it's garbage gary
you talk about volume and quantity but
that's at the expense of quality i'm
like who gets the judge quality
commenters commenters but but that's why
it needs to go out
you know we you know and i think listen
i just think it's an incredible time to
be
creative and i'm pumped um
that you're putting the pieces together
to get there in a world where you've got
40 plus years
to give well you don't know me that well
we'll see how long i don't but i
but when i say that i really genuinely
believe it and you're in a craft
unlike athletes when i say that you know
and we're of the same age milton berle
right
you go jack you know you know like all
you start going into these
names right where you know george burns
you know
bob hope like these all were old [ __ ]
when we were kids but they were still
doing their thing
right yeah i mean i've had uh by the way
are you on a time yeah i i should have
left three minutes ago but i'm enjoying
myself and
i'm literally texting my teeth my
business client to wait a few seconds
okay uh then i'll get to the wrap up
here so
listen listen i just um to me
i found that emotion and not even always
trying to be funny
people people find emotion on the
internet
especially on tick tock and they
gravitate toward that i did those robin
williams thing
i was just like you know i miss him oh
my god where is you know that kind of
thing and people went crazy for that
and it's just a learning experience it's
trying to find out even what people
you know for taking myself out of the
internet for a while and then getting
back
just to see hey frank what actually
worked and what it was
frank think of it this way i'm going to
give you something i'm going to give you
a prescription on my way out
and i think it's going to work for you i
really mean it
make one for them because that's what
you're talking about right now
make one for them and then just make one
for yourself
every time two pills a day one for them
one for you one for them one for you
because i promise you brother on my
[ __ ] heart and soul
the one that you make for yourself is
going to be the one that changes
everything
all right you know you see where i'm
going right yeah
yeah yeah no i my biggest fear is that
so many of the people that fit your
profile are sitting on gold
and will talk themselves out of it for
no reason i'm a big i'm a big talker in
terms of talking myself out of
everything
it's it's why i'm leaning into this one
i i think
what's so amazing about tick-tock for
you
right this second because it will change
the organic reach will go away just like
every platform i've been doing this for
20 years frank the growing like crazy
will just stop because ads are going to
come in it happens on every platform
i've already seen it started
yeah you have 18 months and in that 18
months
i believe that you make up a fake
character because
because we have this talk and you just
decide to do that and that character
becomes your billion dollar t movie
franchise
listen i get no i've been having those
same it's the same things it's just
great to hear from you you're about to
say
i'm having those same thoughts and i'm
just desperately trying to suffocate
it right now from thoughts to action
just make it happen
all right two things the two things
before you get going one do you know how
this interview came about
no and i i'm so glad it did because i
i've learned a lot and i'm going to
utilize it and
uh i know that it was somebody close to
me talking about you like i i've
it's been on my john o'neal sean o'neill
who was a multiple
uh u.s table tennis champion who's
taught me a lot about
uh ping pong table tennis he he texts
him he goes do you want
gary vee on your show i'm like he's not
gonna do the show
uh it's a small little podcast it's just
fun he's like let me
i don't know if you know him personally
or what but
he started uh he did that and then it
worked out nice
since then i've watched a lot more of
your stuff and how you reach out to
charities and that's how i'm thinking of
myself right here
uh no but uh that and i had one he had
one question that i wanted to ask you
for him
quickly which was in terms of sports yes
what do you think kids should do and
this is kind of a reach but
i think do you think they should focus
on one sport or multiple sports is that
multiple sports
because you never know because i think
they should
focus on multiple sports early on and
then if they think they're going to be
professionals they can zone in but i
think the specialization
at the young age right now is more
predicated on delusional parents
that think their kids are going to the
league and i think a lot of times
by limiting children early on you're
taking away
early some skill sets that they might be
able to take i actually think some
parents are going to stop their kids
from going to the league
by making them one dimensional too early
aka
you're going to be a baseball player son
and instead of and what they could have
learned
in basketball or soccer or change them
up a little bit from a
skill set i actually i actually think
it's a huge mistake because
it when i tell you the number one
delusional animal in the world
is parents about their kids going into
sports it's unbelievable to me how many
people are confused
yeah and kid sports are i don't know if
it's just coveted or everything but
it's but it's going way down have you
seen recently yeah the numbers are going
down people are going to lose teamwork
okay i know you got to go the last thing
is
this um with your business acumen and
prowess
how can you wear a jets hat i just don't
understand have you ever have they ever
come to you and said can you talk to us
and help us
the jets were one of my early clients
but the only way i'm going to be able to
help them is to accomplish my lifelong
dream of buying them and then managing
it myself
i can wear it because i love the process
i
i'm loyal it's my squad
i'm not gonna bail just because we're
the worst team in the nfl and that's who
i am
all right i was looking for a joke
answer but i'm glad i got the honesty
you got the one
frank real pleasure man continued
success all right thanks man
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon